.
WHY ARE BOTH PARTIES TRYING TO
PROVOKE RUSSIA INTO USING THE
BOMBERS?
WE'LL ASK COLONEL DOUG
McGREGOR, A RETIRED U.S. ARMY
COLONEL WHO JOINS US NOW.
COLONEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS
EVENING.
A WHIRLWIND WHIPLASH OF NEWS
TODAY WHEN IT COMES TO RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE.
WHAT SHOULD WE MAKE OF IT?
>> WELL, NOT QUITE WHAT SENATOR
GRAHAM HAD TO SAY, OR FOR THAT
MATTER PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE PIPELINE
WAS CLEARLY NOT EXECUTED BY
RUSSIA.
NO ONE BELIEVES THAT.
IN FACT THE GERMAN POPULATION IS
BEING POLLED.
OVERWHELMING IS OPPOSED TO THE
NOTION OF ANY WAR WITH RUSSIA
AND DISMISSES OUT OF HAND THE
NOTION THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PIPELINE.
I THINK THREE THINGS ARE WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW.
FIRST OF ALL, PUTIN HAS DECIDED
THAT NO ONE IN WASHINGTON WILL
NEGOTIATE WITH HIM.
HE KNOWS THAT WASHINGTON IS
ULTIMATELY IN CONTROL.
AND SO HE'S DECIDED THAT IF
RESPONSE HE'S GOT TO ESCALATE
THE MILITARY OPERATION.
PEOPLE AREN'T AWARE OF IT IN THE
WEST, BUT THE RUSSIAN FORCES IN
UKRAINE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
OUTNUMBERED FROM THE DAY THEY
ENTERED UKRAINE.
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE RATHER
THAN DRAMATICALLY.
I SUSPECT THE BOMBERS THAT YOU
REFERRED TO, WHO CARRY BOTH
CONVENTIONAL OR NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
WILL HAVE CONVENTIONAL ARMS, AND
THOSE BOMBERS ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO BE USED IN THE ESCALATION
WE'RE ABOUT TO WITNESS IN
UKRAINE.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO SETTLE
THIS DISPUTE IN UKRAINE ON TERMS
THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE TO RUSSIA
THAT WE MAY NOT LIKE.
OTHER THAN POLAND, NO ONE IN
NATO IS INTERESTED IN GOING TO
WAR WITH RUSSIA.
IF WE PERSIST ON THIS LINE, WE
WILL SEE NATO DISSOLVE AND
FRAGMENT.
>> Will: BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING
THEY WILL NOT FOLLOW POLAND'S
LEAD, NOT STAND TO TOGETHER.
I ASSUME THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, COLONEL?
>> OF COURSE, ABSOLUTELY.
NO ONE WANTS TO GO TO WAR WITH
RUSSIA, OTHER THAN THE POLES AND
A FEW PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Will: THAT WILL BE THE KEY.
THAT WILL BE THE KEY, WHETHER OR
NOT IF THE WORLD DOES NOT FOLLOW
POLAND INTO THE WAR WITH RUSSIA,
WILL THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA PUSH T